Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
This is your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people.
This is BiDiPi.
BUILD IT
Berlin based Korean artist Jeongmoon creates
incredible thread installations.
Audiences are allowed to roam within the rooms
where the colored thread is illuminated by
UV lights.
By giving the room a three dimensional sense
its as thought the viewers have entered a
virtual blueprint.
Jonty Hurwitz creates anamorphic sculptures
that are made by scanned objects distorted
digitally and then fabricated.
But once the sculpture is placed in front
of a cylindrical mirror the reflection reveals
the original image.
Other works are pixelated or sliced human
forms that are only viewable from certain
angles.
Hurwitz, a scientist at heart, claims that
his art is his way of expressing calculations
visually.
Amos Reid and Lasse Ovia from royal collage
of art in London have built a belt driven
mobile espresso bar that they call velopresso.
The bike uses a carbon belt drive system to
power the bike and a custom made coffee grinder
that with five seconds of pedaling will grind
enough coffee for a double shot.
They currently use a camp stove to heat the
water and steam to power the espresso machine
but are working on a way to create their own
fuel using coffee grounds.
DRAW IT
Maurice Bennet creates art with toast.
These portraits are created with thousands
of pieces of bread, toasted to different tones
to create highlights and lowlights.
They're very large and usually displayed as
billboards or in public spaces because the
best view is gained from being a good distance
away from them.
Street artist OakoAk uses stencils and paint
to create works of art around crumbling buildings,
cracks in the ground, and pretty much anywhere
he can create interesting and often humorous
art with.
Including this cinder block scream painting
or storm from the X-Men shooting wall crack
lightning bolts.
Now for the art of scumdance.
The group art show that celebrates famous
movie villains
Designer Matteo of creative studio H-57 made
these minimalist poster designs of popular
movies where the plot is condensed into their
most basic forms.
Including lord of the rings, E.T, The shining,
and the Matrix.
PLAY IT
Here's a cover of the Animals as Leaders song
CAFO by Chino M and his cello
French beatboxer AleM keeps up with a metronome
as it increases in speed
Finally, the music video for Katachi by Shugo
Tokumaru is a multi layered stop motion journey...
Submit your bidipis as a personal message
here on YouTube.
Or share them with everyone over at
the Vsauce2 Facebook page.
Click here to listen to bidipi radio.
Music created and submitted by you guys.
Also check out Your BiDiPi - an entire video
dedicated to your creations.
And as always... thanks for watching.